you can check out Peter Kings NFL column
it is must read every Monday football
morning in America every Monday
exclusively at NBC sports.com Pete got
back from the combine yesterday and he
joins us now biggest topic Pete that you
come back with that you're excited about
Gil grant told me you know he's been
going to the combine for 9,000 years
since the Pleistocene age and he said
that he doesn't remember any player
creating the kind of buzz the tension
must see more than Kyle Emery and you
know Murray is Murray then III I'm
forbidden from telling you which coach
this was but I saw a coach in
Indianapolis jog after the Cuyler Murray
party when he was getting ready to leave
town just because he wanted to meet him
say hello to them and say hey you never
know what might happen and I saw him and
he goes I beg you you know me a solid
and don't say that don't don't say what
you just saw but but that's really kind
of what it was and it isn't that it
isn't that geyser gee whiz I'm a fan of
this guy it's like I want to be in
business with this guy at some point and
so that that obviously was the most
interesting compelling thing and and
again look it could be that all these
defensive guys who are incredibly
talented and have these these great
workouts are going to be great NFL
players but this this guy from from
Mississippi State
you know sweat who ran the ran faster
than Odell Beckham at the Scouting
Combine yeah as soon as I saw that I
called a couple of guys and one of the
one of the guys are like called in the
NFL a long time NFL scout and higher
than that said to me I saw him a lot
this year because we're interested in a
pass rusher in the draft so I
scouted him a lot and he goes he's one
of those guys makes an incredible play
once you say oh my god he's unstoppable
and then he'll disappear for a while and
so even though I do believe that he's
gonna get might even be a first-round
pick that's the problem with so many of
these things at the combine to get
people so excited you remember a couple
of years ago when this receiver from
Washington John Ross knew Branagh four
to two well the headline last week is
Bengals have John Ross on the block they
drafted him whatever it was ninth
overall and now they're trying to dump
him so just you just have to be careful
about what you see this time of year and
I find it really ironic that all the
talk in Indianapolis from whatever there
were 337 players they're all the talk
was about the one guy who did nothing
there but if you're Arizona
how can you I'd take them take them okay
and then you worry about what happens
with with Josh Rosen and I quoted Kurt
Warner in a in a front office a long
time very well-respected general manager
I asked him both this weekend or would
you pay for Josh Rosen what do you think
is market value is and they both said a
third so but but that can't matter in
this you know a year ago the Cardinals
were at 15 and they moved up to ten and
gave a third and a fifth to Oakland to
move up five spots and then they took
Josh Rosen but I feel strongly that you
know so the Bengals looked dumb for
doing what they're doing with John Ross
but if they've decided that he's not a
player and he drops too many balls get
rid of him if he's not helping you win
you know you can't worry about the fact
that you just used the 9th pick on the
draft in two years ago I honestly think
that if they believe that that they want
Kyler Murray they got to get what they
can get to Rosen and just move on and
take the hit that they're gonna take
yeah I was wondering about the Raiders
as still and I thought the Raiders from
the outset with Kyler Murray and now
everybody kind of
realizes you got a special quarterback
you got a you got you got a head coach
who sort of broke the mold you get fired
from Texas Tech and you come in so if
he's coming in I'm thinking out of the
box from the beginning and Josh Rosen
doesn't fit I believe what Kliff
Kingsbury wants to do and you become
relevant like even if Josh Rosen is a
better grade than Kyler Murray Kyler
Murray makes you relevant in the NFL and
you just don't want to be sort of in
that well and you know even though even
though Arizona has done a great job with
attendance you know since they open that
Stadium they might have sold out every
game I don't know you can feel the
market starting to soften you know you
see you know the Diamondbacks and the
Coyotes and what happens when they
perennial II lose you know people don't
come so I believe that if the Cardinals
have two or three more seasons like they
just have all of a sudden that sea of
red becomes a sea of red and gray with
all the empty seats and gray or whatever
the color there but then I'll just say
one other thing you know about John
group now look someone in Indianapolis
told me Jon Gruden is the worst poker
player in the NFL because you know he
and mike Mayock and I believe Mike may I
might truly believe but but he and Mike
Mac can talk all they want about about
how they love Derek Carr and indeed they
may love Derek Carr but I'm telling you
Jon Gruden is very very interested in
Tyler Perry yeah very interested so all
I can say on that one is stay tuned and
I don't know if he's going to be able to
engineer anything to move up if he loves
them that much I think he does but well
time will tell we'll see what happens it
may all be moot if Arizona decides
they're going to pick them and says
we're not listening to anything then
maybe we'll maybe all look like a fool
for saying Jon Gruden love Tyler Perry
because he'll never have had to act on
it if you know what I mean yep Skyler
Murray but but it but he may not he may
be able to tell he may be able to tell
Derek Carr don't believe what you read
yeah that was going to be the guest the
coach that ran after Kyler Murray's
group I know you can't mention any
but that was going to be that was gonna
be my guest John bruton's running up to
say hello to Kyler Murray's party but
you you know I think the interesting
thing the Nick Foles
is signed sealed delivered here to
Jacksonville foregone conclusion this
week you know I don't I don't know Dan
but I kept hearing in in Indianapolis
that that's the only team that really
wants them I don't think giant solanum
make Washington has some interest but
the problem that that is you know when I
was talking to people out there
the problem is you're not positive you
love Nick Foles in January you know you
you love them in the postseason but and
you love him that one year in Philly but
man he's he's had some he's had some ap
days under center in the NFL now you can
say well everybody does you know under
the st. Louis Rams in the dying days of
Jeff Fisher I get it but I'm just not
positive that there is the absolute
consistent you know it basically
absolute consistent record of work that
that Nick Foles has that somebody says
I'm Peyton I'm making him this year's
Kirk Cousins obtaining 28 million year
now I know what Jacksonville I assume
it's Jacksonville it's what everybody
says it's what everybody Andy thinks so
I don't know what they'll pay him but I
just I think there's the reason that the
market is not broiling hot when Miami
needs a quarterback when Washington
needs a quarterback yeah it's funny Dan
I sensed some significant interest out
there in Teddy Bridgewater and obviously
Teddy Bridgewater has nothing of the
resume of Nick Foles I mean Nick Foles
outdueled the great Belichick you know
just 13 months ago so I I mean look and
and I'll and I'll just say this a hats
off to the Eagles for for letting trolls
go but don't just think it's all an
altruistic act because I think the
Eagles didn't really believe they get
much more than a three so by doing a
good deed
yeah and allowing Nick Foles his freedom
to go choose whatever team he wants even
if it's a one team filled honestly still
gonna get a three next year as a
compensatory pick so it's not it's not
the ultimate act of selflessness why the
Philadelphia Eagles final topic I think
this guy needs an intervention Antonio
Brown it is he talking to himself into a
job or is he talking himself out of jobs
i Dan I heard that you know Adam
Schefter report I think he's absolutely
right Oakland Washington Tennessee I
heard yesterday morning before I left
town there's one other team now so it
sounds like oh it sounds like Pittsburgh
is going to be able to make a deal as
early as this week that's what I wrote
this morning that they're confident that
they can get not market value but they
can get more than a lot of people think
they get and I picked it as if I had to
go to Vegas right now and you said
what's the over-under on the pick in the
draft that Pittsburgh will get free
Antonio Brown I would take it at number
27 which ironically he the pick that
Oakland acquired for Amari Cooper and in
the long run even though I think Oakland
did a terrible job in trading Kaleo Matt
if you were to ask me right now who
would you rather have for the next three
years Amari Cooper Antonio Brown Orton
all I'd rather have a Antonio Brown even
though then there's no question I wrote
this a couple of weeks ago that Antonio
Brown has absolutely sullied his market
value if he had just shut up for the
last nine weeks said absolutely nothing
just disappeared went into a monastery
the Pittsburgh Steelers would get a lot
better
take a free Antonio Brown than this yeah
any he wants a new contract and I know
he says it's not about the money I don't
think he can I don't think he can get
one right away I will be I will be very
surprised if he gets one right away
because what I think you'd be foolish if
I were a team that would be that would
make me not trade for I'd have to say to
Drew Rosenhaus say listen we're not
making this deal
we're not giving them a new contract in
year one after this year we'll see let's
see how it develops but if I were a team
I'd rather train won't have them play
that first year if it's a disaster just
cut them let them become a free agent
somewhere then then give them new money
right now because that could turn out to
be a disaster Pete thank you for your
time we appreciate it great read this
morning the football morning in America
column every Monday on NBC sports.com
Thank You Pete they really appreciated
in all the bestia that's Peter King for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
channel 239 on Direct TV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]